هنا منزل عائله عبد الهادي في منطقه ابو
عريف في دير البلح تعرضت قبل قليل ايضا
لغار جويه اسرائيليه عنيفه تم تدمير
المنزل بشكل كامل وهنا الحديث يدور عن
اعداد كبيره من المصابين وما زال الاعمل
الجاري في هذه الاوقات لاخراج اعداد اخرى
من تحت
الانقاض
هنا الجميع يعمل في هذه الاوقات الصعبه
وبامكانيات قليله ايضا لمحاوله الوصول
للناجين الجميع يحاول اخماد النيران التي
اشتعلت داخل هذا المنزل بعد الغاره الجويه
الاسرائيليه على هذا
المكان قلنا قبل شوي في شم منغا تحت هذ
دار اربع طوابق مختار كوكبه يا عمي هذا
مختار كوكبه الزلمه بالش مالوش دعوه في اي
حاجه حرام عليهم بيعملو اربع طوابق نزلوها
ف فوق روسهم كلهم ما يقارب 10 عائلات ما
يقارب 100 نفر هنا في الدار هذه مش واحد
ولا اثنين ولا ع ايش طلع عليهم ولا
ب
علع لرا ارجع لورا
ارجع ارجع
[موسيقى]
الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه نفذت في
الساعه الاخيره غارات متتاليه على مدينه
دير البلح حيث منزل ايضا اخر في منطقه حكر
الجامع لعائله ابو الروس تم تدمير هذا
المنزل بشكل كامل والطواقم ايضا هناك تعمل
للوصول الى مزيد من الشهداء والناجين من
هذه الغاره الان يتم اخراج اعداد من
المواطنين من تحت انقاذ هذه البنايه
لعائله عبد الهادي في منطقه ابو عريف وا
اصحاب المكان يتحدثون عن شهداء كثر جراء
هذه الغاره الاسرائيليه وان اعداد
النازحين هنا يفوق ال 100 شخص كانوا بداخل
هذا المنزل الذي تم تدميره بشكل كامل قبل
قليل عبر تنفيذ الطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه سلسله غارات قويه جدا على دير
البلح وسط
القطاع هنا مسجد الشهداء في غرب مدينه دير
البلح حيث كان ياوي اعدادا كبيره في محيط
المسجد من النازحين الفلسطينيين حيث اغارت
الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه وبدون سابق
انذار فتره اذان الظهر وهذا التوقيت يكون
هذا الشارع وهذا المحيط ممتلئ تماما
بالمواطنين والنازحين والتي تاوي هذه
المنطقه ايضا اعداد من مدارس الاونر والتي
بداخلها عشرات الالاف من النازحين
الفلسطين الذين جاؤوا من مدينه غزه ومن
شمال القط هذه المنطقه تعد من المناطق
الامنه ولكن بدون سابق انذار هنا اغارت
الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه على هذا
المسجد وقد دمرته بشكل كامل في هذه
الاوقات غرب مدينه دير البلح تعد من
المناطق المقتضى وفيها كتله بشريه هائله
من المواطنين الذين يتجمعون من كل مكان
اعداد كبيره من الشهداء والمصابين تم
نقلهم من هنا باتجاه مستشفى شهداء الاقصى
في دير البلح المواطنين يتحدثون عن غاره
جويه قيه وعنيفه جدا على هذا المربع
السكني والذي ياوي منازل شعبيه بسيطه هنا
في مخيم دير البلح وسط
القطاع
موبق هذه الغه غارات اخرى على مدينه دير
البلا حيث وتيره الغارات الجويه
الاسرائيليه ارتفعت خلال الساعات الماضيه
على المحافظه الوسطى وعلى مدينه دير البلح
حتى المساجد ودور العباده لم تسلم من
الغارات الجويه الاسرائيليه خلال الساعات
الاخيره اشرف ابو عمره الجزيره دير البلح
وسط قطاع
غزه